once again things go bump in the night
and once again they make a movie about
it don't be afraid of the dark although
you probably should be if you have a
creepy uncle right so I never saw a
trailer to this movie so I didn't know
what to expect but don't be afraid of
the dark stars Guy Pearce Katie Holmes
and some little girl and they live in
this really big creepy ass house like
Malfoy Manor or something and of course
there are things in which you should
probably be afraid of the dark for me
the beginning of this movie is like the
creepiest part there's this really
creepy guy it takes place in the year
like 1800 something but this creepy guy
does something to you I was like oh god
I can't watch it was pretty
cringe-worthy and it happened at the
very beginning no part in this movie was
ever as good as that so it's kind of
just downhill from there seriously
though it was like bite the kerb in
American History X no now when things go
bump tonight it's one of three things
either a crazy guy a ghost or a little
creature without giving it away too much
this one's a little creatures not a
ghost at this point in my life once I
see what goes bump in the night it loses
me I'm like I already know now it's not
creepy a couple parts I did jump at it
was because of jump scares you know how
I hate those movie should not rely on
jump scares this does not to say these
little things aren't creepy little
bastards I'm just saying they're not
creepy to an adult it's like I can
guarantee you if a kid sees this movie
they're gonna be scared shitless if I
saw this as a kid I wouldn't sleep for
years but since I didn't I'm gonna go to
bed tonight and I'm just gonna sleep
like a baby
actually correction I'm gonna stay up
all night but not because I'm scared cuz
I need to go to pax in the morning and
I'm just not gonna sleep because I'm
scared and it concentrates a lot on the
relationship between Katie Holmes and
this little girl you know stepmom
daughter kind of you don't care you
just want to see the little vermicious
knids or whatever scare the out of
this kid what happens it's just not
scary so it's like this is a scary movie
that will only scare kids but if parents
take their kids to see this movie
they're they are people a
couple of intense scenes though a couple
times you're like dude so in the end I
will say it's alright but you're not
gonna remember it in t-minus one night
which we'll see if I do sleep at night
and I do get creeped out if I'm thinking
about this movie I'll put an annotation
right there saying yes Jeremy was
creeped out then again I do videos at
night and sleep during the day so I feel
like I'm a bad example when you were a
kid what creeped the living out of
you comment below let me know for me it
was the bumble from Rudolph look at that
dude scared the living piss out of me
how did they think that was okay for a
kid to watch seriously in any case if
you like what you seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more